We think quantum computers will allow us to solve some problems faster than we can with classical computers alone. But
understanding how is subtle. Today in Qiskit in the classroom, we'll try to uncover the source of the power of
quantum computing by looking at one of the very first
algorithms. Welcome to Qiskit in the classroom. In this series, we'll use Qiskit to explore some fundamental
concepts commonly covered in quantum computing related courses. Each video is accompanied by an interactive module
linked in the description below. So, be sure to check that out. If you've heard much about quantum computers, you've
probably heard that they can use quantum phenomena like superposition, entanglement, and interference to solve
problems in ways classical computers can't. But how exactly do these features help? In 1985, David Deutsch was the
first to show how this could happen. He came up with what is now called Deutsche's algorithm that could solve a
problem more efficiently than a classical algorithm could. Today, we'll take a look at Deutsche's algorithm and
a later extension called the Deutsch Jose algorithm and examine how the uniquely quantum aspects of the cubits
can be used to the quantum computers benefit. Then we'll run these algorithms on a real quantum computer with Kiskit.
There are other quantum algorithms out there that also show a theoretical advantage over known classical algorithms. And not all of them work
with the same principles as those we'll see today. So what we'll learn today doesn't explain in general how a quantum
computer works, but it does help us begin to see how the principles of quantum mechanics can be combined to
make a powerful quantum computer. Before diving into Deutsche's algorithm, let's first think about how quantum computers
are different from classical computers and how that might give us an advantage in solving certain
problems. One difference is that the quantum bits called cubits can be in superposition states. Instead of being
limited to either the zero state or the one state as a classical bit is a cubit
can be in a superposition state of both zero and one. We write this state like
this where a and b are complex numbers whose squares add up to one and the more
cubits the more this gap extends. Two bits can still be in only one of these
four possible states. 0 0 1 1 0 or 1
1. Two cubits can be in a superp position of all four of those classically allowed states which is
written like this. In general, a classical system of n bits can only ever be in just one of 2 to the n possible
combinations of zeros and ones. A quantum system of n cubits can be in a superposition of all 2 to the n of these
states. The scaling is exponential. So even if we had just 10 cubits, they
could be in a superposition state of 2 to the 10, which is 1,024 possible combinations of zeros and
ones. The exponential scaling of the state space of cubits is called quantum
parallelism and is partially responsible for the advantage of quantum computers over classical computers. But a quantum
computer is not just a massive parallel processor. Just because the cubits in a quantum computer can be in a
superposition of exponentially many states doesn't mean we have access to all the information in each of these
states. Since measurement collapses the system into one state or another, let's
see how this plays out in a simple problem. Say there's some machine that
you can feed a single bit to. Then it will apply some function to the bit and spit out another single bit. The machine
is inside a black box that we can't access. All we have access to is the bit
we feed it x and the bit that the box spits out f
ofx. We want to figure out what is the function f that the machine is applying.
There are four possible functions that take a single bit to another single bit.
So to find out what the function is, we can just feed it a zero and see if it spits out a zero or a one. then feed it
a one and do the same thing. Each of these two steps is called a query. This
is one way to compare classical and quantum algorithms through the so-called query model where we compare the number
of queries each of the algorithms need to make of the black box in order to solve the problem. So in this case, our
classical method needed to query the box twice to learn the function. Let's see if we can do better if we have a quantum
computer query the black box. Instead of first feeding a zero and then a one, the
quantum computer can feed the box a cubit that's in a superp position of zero and
one. So in effect, we're feeding the box both inputs with a single query. Then
does that mean that we can learn the function with only one query?
Unfortunately, that's not the case. We see why this idea fails when we test it on a quantum computer. We'll make a
circuit with two cubits. Cubit zero represented here by this top line will be our input state X that we feed to the
black box which was shown here by the maroon gate labeled UF. The UF gate is
designed to take a cubit zero as the input state X then apply a transformation on cubit one that takes
the state zero to the state f ofx. So as long as cubit 1 started in the state
zero then the output is x on cubit 0 and f ofx on cubit 1. So to find f ofx for
both x=0 and x= 1 simultaneously we can try putting cubit 0 in a superposition of 0 and 1 before
we feed it to the black box. That's done with this red hatom gate which transforms the zero state to 1 / 2
0 + 1. So after the blackbox gate, we should now have a superposition of both
f of0 and f of 1 on cubit 1. When we measure the two cubits, we're hoping to
answer the question, what function is inside the black box. Let's use the kiskuit primitive sampler to run the
circuit and return the result. We can choose the number of times the circuit is run called samples by changing this
parameter called shots here.